good morning John I love audiobooks like
I love them a lot and not in that like
oh well I don't have that much time to
read any more and so I mostly just
listen to audio books because that's
better than not reading at all kind of
way no I love them on their own as a
medium I find them wonderful I love book
book reading as well I love cascading
into this story into this physical
object that has all these marks on a
page that turn into this story in my
mind there's nothing in the world like
that but there's also nothing in the
world like being told a story that's the
oldest thing there is that and like
maybe music I think it's like what made
us human and maybe like music and
stories at the same time is every song a
story
think about it and get back to me it's
been a fair amount of talk about whether
it listening to an audiobook counts as
reading or if it's like cheating these
conversations to me seem to be based in
two different things one like
scientifically psychologically is it the
same no like subjectively I can say that
it's not the same a narrator of an
audiobook makes a bunch of decisions for
me before the information gets to my
brain I might be making some of those
decisions differently so I think the
story is in some ways slightly different
when it's being read to me and it seems
like retention is measurably better on
average when read rather than when being
read to that's on average and it's
actually different from person to person
this to me doesn't seem like a judgment
of better or worse it seems like it's
marginally different like that
tremendously but somewhat different the
second place that this conversation
comes from though is I think from people
who have a lot of pride in their
identity as a reader or as a reader of a
lot of books people love reading lots of
books and they see that as part of what
makes them valuable and exceptional I
think those people are kind of just
saying like part of why I'm proud of
myself is that I read a lot of books the
fact that like somebody got through a
lot of books in audio form isn't the
same as the thing that I'm proud of a
lot of people push back against this as
like exclusionary but like all forms of
exceptionality are exclusionary you have
a really hard time as
humans figuring out why we matter and
there are much worse ways to find pride
than like the length of your book list
but I'm never gonna be one of those
people who reads a lot of books in a
year I'm mildly dyslexic according to
this staples.com reading test I read
slower than the average 8th grader that
doesn't mean that I don't love reading I
totally do and it doesn't mean that
audiobooks are a replacement for books
for me I like audiobooks as a way to
enjoy a story to me media is about like
enjoying being a human and loving having
a good story told to me by a good
storyteller is probably something that I
have in common with every single one of
my human ancestors and that's pretty
cool and it's part of why I pushed
pretty hard for our new year of life's
library to have an audiobook option so
now you can be a part of this community
of readers all consuming the same stuff
and connecting about it and when you
sign up you can choose the audio version
with digital perks or with physical
perks and every time we start a new book
you'll get a code emailed to you you
click on that code and into your libro
FM account will arrive the new book I'm
curating a month of this year's life
library I chose a book that I have read
both in book form and audio form I know
it's good both ways we decided to do
this with libro FM because they are just
great don't have to be a paying member
of libro FM to get your book but you can
be and if you are you get to choose
which book store you would like to order
your audiobooks from so you can support
book stores in your community and of
course just like with regular books you
get to keep your audiobook even if you
can't see your life's library
subscription so join life's library
there's a link in the description or you
can just click right there I had to put
a video here because YouTube doesn't let
us link to anything unless we also link
to a video I don't know why I find it
annoying John I'll see you on Tuesday